hey there i'm mr woof and i'm a high
school teacher from sydney australia
i teach mathematics you need the
derivative of the inside as well as the
derivative of the outside
right so if it looked like this you
wouldn't have any trig substitution
all right now this is a really good
example of thinking about
the two kinds of limits that we were
looking at before from above
and from below i teach technology the
fact is decision support systems
it's a very very broad category okay we
have a whole piece of technology to
avoid it
to try to work out what's the fastest
route
i answer questions about christianity it
was god's plan to make us immortal from
the beginning
but he wanted to make us more than
immortal jesus rescues us
from every lousy master that's out there
and when i say master i mean anything
that we follow
anything that we trust in for security
and leadership
and every now and then i make videos
about other random things too
why are exams so hard why do teachers
make exams so hard
growing up i was given a world-class
education for free
and now through the wonder of the
internet i want to share some of that
with you too
so i hope you find these videos helpful
consider subscribing
and happy learning
you